foreign
was it right
what I did
ask me again in 10 years
try not to worry Ollie I've been
worrying about John for years
he always comes back
Realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
you forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones update
video in this video I want to reveal
some new information about the Jon Snow
show HBO has been developing as I'm sure
all of you know by now HBO has been
developing a new show with actor kit
Harrington who we all know as Jon Snow
from the original Game of Thrones series
this is something he has been working on
with HBO and George RR Martin ever since
the original show ended over three years
ago as of right now we don't know
exactly what they will have Jon Snow do
in this show all we know is the Jon Snow
series will be set in Westeros after the
events of the Game of Thrones season 8
finale now HBO hasn't released their own
official announcement about this show
however it has already been confirmed by
Amelia and George RR Martin himself and
after the major success of House of the
Dragon I am sure HBO is more than ready
to get another Game of Thrones series
out to the fans we all know there's
still a massive demand for all things A
Song of Ice and Fire in this new
interview Game of Thrones actress
Gwendolyn Christy who we all know as
Brienne reveals not only is there
another show in development at HBO but
she's also had a conversation about it
with its creator Mr Jon Snow himself let
me show you what she said then I'll give
my thoughts on what this might mean for
the future of Game of Thrones okay I
have to ask Game of Thrones is there any
chance that your character would make an
appearance in the new Jon Snow spin-off
oh in the new Jon Snow spin-off well I
really don't know about that I think it
depends um if Kit Harington remembers
quite how many favors he owes me and if
the writing's any good I believe he's
doing it himself
no I have spoken to get about it and I'm
really delighted for him he was so
um legendary in that role really he's a
great actor kit Harrington and he
committed his life to that role and I
think we all want to see more of it well
I would personally love if you got to
make an appearance congratulations on
the show I'm so excited for everyone to
see it thank you have the best time
tonight
all right so as you can see she said she
did have a conversation about it with
Harrington so once again we know this is
a real show they're still actively
working on we also know that she does
want to be in the show she has already
said that in another interview the only
thing that would most likely stop her
from showing up in this Jon Snow series
is if she's not written into the show
like she just said in this new interview
since kid Harrington is having his own
guys write the show then it's really up
to them if they want to try and have
other Game of Thrones characters come
back into the story as we all know when
Game of Thrones ended many of them were
still alive we already know who is with
Jon Snow north of the wall but we also
know that Starks are still alive as well
like Sansa bran and Arya we also know
Brianne Tyrion Braun Davos Gendry gray
worm and many others are still out there
living in Westeros and even Beyond not
only are all these characters still
alive but many other actors have already
said they would gladly work on this show
again Maisie Williams who was Arya Stark
said she would be in another game of own
show John Bradley who we all know as
Samwell also said the same thing even
demelia had some fun with the idea
although we all know she is dead right
now
I mean it's just difficult because
spoiler generous dies
[Applause]
this is very exciting because it gives
kit Harrington a lot of new options for
the story he doesn't only have to be in
the show himself out beyond the wall
with nothing to do obviously they would
have to give him a good reason to move
South again and while he's on that
Adventure he could start reuniting with
a lot of his old friends or enemies
Jacob Anderson who we all know is
greyworm also weighed in on the Jon Snow
show this is what he had to say
I'm very yeah he's one of my favorites I
think it would be pretty tense if he did
I think the only way that gray worm
would show up in that shot is to kill
Jon Snow
I don't think gray one would want to see
him again I think like that was quite a
significant condition of of him living
was like I don't ever want to see your
face again I'm Gonna Go My Way and
you're gonna go your way and that's
that's that I'd be very surprised if we
saw a gray worm again now he says he
would be very surprised if gray worm
wasn't the new show but I think that's
only because he doesn't expect him to
bring him back he didn't actually say
he's not interested I think he just
means he doesn't believe they would
bring gray worm all the way back from
essos just to have a showdown with Jon
Snow I disagree though I think it would
be amazing if gray worm did come back
because he found out Jon Snow was no
longer north of the wall or dare I say
if Daenerys was resurrected I would love
to see him at her side again that would
actually be amazing although I know it's
not as likely now another thing I really
loved about this new interview is how
Gwendolyn said she is delighted for
kidari we know she's had a conversation
with him about the show so she most
likely knows a lot more about what's
happening behind the scenes than any of
us and the fact that she's so happy for
him lets me know that he must have said
something that revealed the Jon Snow
show is still moving full steam ahead I
hope this means that HBO will finally
make an announcement of their own very
soon as always I will make sure to let
you know any and everything that is
happening with this new Jon Snow series
or House of the dragon's second season
or any other Game of Thrones shows
they're developing at HBO make sure you
subscribe that way you're always first
to know whenever something new happens
like I have said before I will be here
making new videos every single week
during the whole off season of House of
the Dragon there's a lot more stuff
still heading your way once again I want
to thank all of you for watching my
video I hope all of you have a great day
I will see you again very soon
bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign